former Dunder Mifflin paper salesman an
assistant to the regional manager Dwight
Schrute is loud intense and one of
televisions most memorable dunces
however even though the titular offices
doors have been shuttered for a while
now there's still a lot you might not
know about the beat loving karate
kicking owner of shriek farms Dwight
Schrute and Rainn Wilson seem as
inseparable as bears beats Battlestar
Galactica as difficult as it is to
imagine anyone other than Wilson playing
Dunder Mifflin Scranton fire safety
chief it's utterly impossible to
contemplate what would have happened if
one famous comedian who auditioned for
the role had actually gotten it in 2013
the final season of the office was
released on DVD and included in the
extras is a short video revealing some
of the actors who auditioned for the
series among other noteworthy surprises
Bob Odenkirk of better call Saul Fame
auditioned for the role of Michael Scott
Kathryn Hahn tried out for Pam and both
John Cho and Adam Scott took a crack at
Jim Halpert but perhaps most surprising
of all is that Seth Rogen tried his best
to land the part of Dwight Schrute urine
is sterile did you know that if you're
in the field you can clean the man's
room by taking a whiz on it that is
actually in first aid books written by
the Red Cross what's most fascinating
about the clip is how apparent it is
that Rogen's Dwight wouldn't have been
within a galaxy of the same character
Wilson gave us reading the same line
Dwight would be obnoxious and
condescending speaking as if he were
delivering the lesson to a child Rogan
seems absolutely likeable not very
bright and not at all shrewd ish kind of
like Kevin the accountant DeFede knew a
few more factoids and was awake for more
of the day throughout the course of the
office Dwight Schrute both worships
Michael Scott and has ambitions for his
office and in one of the many ways in
which life imitates art Rainn Wilson
didn't initially audition for the role
of assistant to the regional manager he
wanted to be the big dog himself much
like Bob Odenkirk Wilson went into his
audition taking aim at the role of
everybody's favorite regional manager
Michael Scott alas it wasn't meant to be
possibly because as Wilson puts it his
audition of mounded
a quote terrible ricky gervais sin
personation yeah I originally I
auditioned for both the Michael Scott
role The Steve Carell role and the
Dwight roll but my audition for the for
the Michael Scott role was just terrible
considering how amazing Wilson is as
Schrute as well as Steve Carell success
as the equally clueless Michael Scott
it's probably for the best it might be
interesting to take a peek in the
alternate reality where Wilson got cast
as Michael Scott in January 2012
Dateline reported NBC was considering an
office spin-off with Rainn Wilson
starring as Dwight Schrute the farm
would have been a family comedy and a
setting office fans had grown familiar
with over the years Schrute farms among
others the series would have featured
Matt Jones aka badger from breaking bad
as Dwight's cousin Zeke veteran
character actor Tom Bauer as Dwight's
not see uncle Hinrich Thomas Middleditch
of Silicon Valley fame as Dwight's
Bigfoot hunting brother Jeb and
Venezuelan born mohandro Delfino as
Dwight's sister Fanny of course Michael
sure would reprise his role as two
White's creepy neck bearded cousin Mose
remember my cousin Mose welcome children
were you painting in the dark for better
or worse the farm wasn't meant to be
in October 2012 Wilson tweeted the news
that NBC had passed on the series
although he'd quote had a blast making
the pilot the pilot for the farm was
then recut as a single office episode in
the show's final season but would that
story have worked as a full-fledged
series it's hard to say but vulture
writer Matt simcha wits notes that
Dwight's popularity came mainly from him
acting as an antagonist to Jim Halpert
making him the lead in a comedy series
about a disjointed family that he's
expected to bring together changes
Dwight's role dramatically to quote the
likable hero we've never seen in other
words maybe it's best that we never
visited the farm from his obsession with
having a second second life to his epic
sales struggle with a supposedly
self-aware AI Dwight is well known for
some of his online shenanigans what you
might not know is that Rainn Wilson used
to maintain a blog in Dwight's voice
unfortunately it doesn't exist anymore
but NBC used to host Schrute space which
let fans read Dwight's thoughts on
different Scranton radio stations or his
in
martial arts tips while NBC eventually
opened the blog up to the masses it
started as something that existed
exclusively on the set of the office the
computers on the offices set were
networked together and Wilson would
write the Dwight voiced blog while
scenes were being filmed so the rest of
the cast could enjoy it Wilson told The
Morning Call that during the filming the
pilot episode quote the producer saw the
blog when they walked by and thought it
was funny a few emails later between NBC
and Wilson and Schrute space was born
now if only NBC would bring it back the
world would be a better place oh well
there's always Creed's blog wwq H gov w
w backslash Creed thoughts
check it out in 2015 Rainn Wilson's
memoir the bassoon King Arts idiocy and
other assorted tales from the band room
was released and like many non-fiction
books a different author was invited to
write the foreword namely the foreword
is credited to Dwight Kurt Schrute and
it's written entirely in Dwight's
disdainful voice troupe spends the first
bit of the foreword discussing why he's
agreed to write it which he clearly
doesn't want to he explains when someone
asks me to do a task the first thing I
do is determine whether the request is
some sort of trick while the job of
writing the foreword survives
Dwight's vetting process he tells us
that he doesn't like the bassoon king or
any books that involve quote funny
stories regarding some stupid actor and
then he promptly proceeds to list a long
number of exceptions to this which
include books by Charles Bronson any
Game of Thrones cast member Sam Neill
and Dolph Lundgren
Dwight calls Rainn Wilson a laughable
idiot and eventually reveals he has only
agreed to write the foreword for the
money before turning things over to
Wilson Dwight gives us some other book
ideas like Mennonite ghost stories a fun
games for kids book titled hold this
book over a candle and the revealing
conspiracy theories who's really behind
them seriously we'll take a whole book
written by Dwight please check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]